but I couldn't say that it would be any
problem that you must face when you want
to work as an engineer
thank you very much I'm gonna do
something very unpolite and because
we're gonna start continue the next the
next talk and we are also already live
on YouTube so I hope you're aware of
that we are I think your life on the
YouTube again yes so so okay let's
unmute Alan hi Alan so I'll give a small
introduction to who you are so people
know who they're referring to and who's
talking to them and who's presenting
something so our next speaker is Alan he
is
currently a professor at the Humboldt
University a recent professor from the
beginning of this year he started his
position at the home board University
before that he was working at research
labs in the industry at solando IBM if
I'm not mistaken and has completed his
PhD only five years or six years ago
which is in my opinion very quick to
advance to full professorship no no yeah
it is full yeah exactly it was a tenure
track professor ship so I congratulate
again and he will talk about his flair
tool layer library which is available on
github you can check it out there's a
link on the meetup page and he will tell
us a lot about NLP and how his Flair
Network and embedding is basically
treating language so thank you yeah
thanks for the nice introduction maybe
the first question how much time do I
have before the talk I think half an
hour's it's good and then we have the
question okay I couldn't make it a bit
faster that's good like I think it's
good
okay then let me share my screen and
thank you very much for the nice
introduction so can you see this yes
okay RIT okay yeah great so I'd like to
talk about the Flair framework and was
very good with his introduction so you
basically allow me to skip my first
slides because you said everything what
we do in my group at the University is
we develop the open source NOP framework
flare so and this is really what this
talk is about to start at the beginning
so we
the development started in my previous
company so before I joined the
University I was at Solano research here
in Berlin in the NLP research department
and the company actually had a lot of
text data that we wanted to analyze and
for instance we wanted to do named
entity recognition on this text data so
Xylon low because I understand actually
there's a lot of people who are outside
of Berlin in this talk so Zalando is
actually a big fashion company in Europe
and so basically we had a lot of text
data in the domain of fashion like this
blog post right and what we wanted to do
was we wanted to identify words and
groups of words that belong to certain
semantic categories like colors or
fashion items or like fashion brands
like this kind of stuff so this is a
fairly standard named entity recognition
task and there were different types of
text mining that we wanted to do but
when we started our work actually we
were kind of unhappy so we looked at all
the research papers or some of the
research papers and we were kind of
unhappy with the general reproducibility
of of the research results that we were
reading about because they were talking
about these great numbers and it was
somewhat difficult to reproduce and so
some of the problems that we had was for
instance that some papers only report
the results but don't actually open
source their code right so you see these
great numbers but it's pretty hard to
actually reproduce them unless you sit
down and implement it all yourself but
the problem here of course is that a lot
of research papers don't have all the
technical details right a special case
of this is that some people say that
they will release their code but they
actually never do but it's the same
situation in the end you don't have the
codes another thing that we encountered
a lot is that code is actually released
that belongs to a paper but it's
actually really hard to get running
right so it's basically really hard to
read and it has a lot of dependencies so
basically we kind of refer to this as
fake reproducibility because on the one
hand the code is there but on the other
hand it's actually not super usable
and the final case was script produces
numbers and we encountered this a few
times that the research code is released
and it doesn't run but then it just like
this massive script you get the line
that you have to execute it runs forever
and at the end comes out a number let's
say 42 that matches the number in the
paper but you really don't know what's
going on right so we were generally
unhappy with the reproducibility and
this is I think it is slowly getting
better but generally this is I think a
problem along in many machine learning
disciplines right so for instance if you
look at named entity recognition today
right now if you look at the top five
papers I think three of them don't
actually open source the code so you
can't reproduce it so it's it's still a
it's still a big issue so we thought
okay so what are the deezee data for
reproducibility so what we like so this
is all very obvious stuff so we would
like a very quick setup so we would like
the framework the algorithms to be set
up very quickly on your machine but also
to include all the datasets that we need
in order to run the experiments if the
experiments require models such as
embedding models they should all be
included so all of this should be there
right we also thought it should be
modular in the sense that the code
should be easy to read to understand
what part of the code does what and also
make it easy to switch out components so
for instance in NLP you do a lot with
embeddings so let's say you have a
research result that uses cloth
embeddings and to make it actually
really easy to switch out a different
embedding layer like a bird embedding
layer in there right we also would like
the code to be applicable to new data
sets and tasks meaning that the code
should not have any specific assumptions
about the data right so it should just
be usable to take those research result
and apply it to my task right and
finally it should be easy to build on
top and I mean if you look at this slide
this is all super obvious right so this
is not no rocket science here and if you
do part of speech tagging and look at
the adjectives on the slides you're
gonna find the words easy used a lot and
the word quick which in this case is
cinnamon for easy
so basically what we really wanted was
research that is easy to reproduce and
also research that is easy to apply and
this kind of motivated us to develop the
Flair framework the tagline is a very
simple framework for state-of-the-art
NLP and the two crucial parts are very
simple so it should be easy to use and
state-of-the-art meaning that it uses
recent NLP research and makes it
applicable for for everybody now Flair
is built on high torch which is a one of
the most popular deep learning
frameworks and it's actually an official
part of the plant torch ecosystem and it
is very very much an open source project
so it sits in an open library but
there's no company behind it so we're
not we're not selling it we're not
making any money so basically the whole
development of this project has
basically been driven by open source
community and contributions from a lot
of people so without the open source
community this project would definitely
not exist and would not look anyway like
this so what we originally open source 2
years ago
looked very very different from this and
it's actually the involvement of the
open source community that trained new
models and added features and fixed a
million books that made this framework
alright we're currently at version zero
point four point five and we have a new
big release coming this week I wanted to
have it done before this talk but
unfortunately it didn't happen so but
it's coming this week you know so what
is Flair so there's essentially two
views on it for most users it's an NLP
library what it allows you to do is to
use NLP models on your text and there's
a lot of models that we just include and
I'm going to show you a bunch of demos
for some of the models are included that
you can basically just use as they are
another thing that a lot of people do is
they use the library to train your own
models because there's a lot of things
like languages or tags that may be very
specific to your use cases and so the
library makes it easy for you to train
your own NOP models and the uptake
actually is
tremendous so thanks again to this to
the open source community it's used in
hundreds of dependents and open source
projects and I know a lot of companies
are using it in this way a lot of
startups and medium-sized and even large
companies are using it the other point
of view that's more relevant I think too
you know University where I'm at right
now is that it's an NLP experimentation
framework so essentially there's a big
focus on word embeddings and text
embeddings in the framework and standard
NLP pipelines and so essentially what
you can do is you could develop a new
word embedding or a new text embedding
you can plug it into the framework and
basically run it in default
NOP pipelines to see what the impact is
on downstream tasks so we include a lot
of like standard data sets and standard
pipelines where you can immediately see
what's going on now however on this talk
there's we're not going to talk about
the research at all instead I'm just
gonna walk you through the framework I'm
gonna show you how you can use these
models and I'm gonna show you maybe time
permitting probably not how to train
your own models okay okay so we're gonna
do a walk through together
setting up Flair is very easy just like
the previous project all you have to do
is pip install Flair it requires at
least Python 3.6 and you can do it for
instance an online environment like
collab so it's it should be very simple
to setup and then once you have this
done you can actually already start
tagging your text one big task that we
support this text classification and in
text classification what you want to do
is you want to take a piece of text and
automatically detect whether it belongs
to one or multiple predefined categories
alright so a very classic example of
this is sentiment analysis so where you
want to detect is this takes written in
a positive way or in a negative way
right so somebody writes I really like
this movie because you want to predict
that it's positive and if somebody
writes I really hated this movie because
you want to predict negative right
and text Asif occations actually super
versatile you can use it in a million
different use cases
another one is hate speech detection
this is a German example where you want
to find out like is this speech hate
speech is offensive language yes or no
and if it is offensive language which
type of offensive languages is so in
this example do pistol blah blah
would be an insult right in fact it's
very versatile you use it for intent
detection if you use it for many
different use cases and what I want to
do now is I want to show you a demo of
one of the taggers that we have and
flare in action for sentiment analysis
all right so I'm going to try this I'm
gonna exit this so the first question
would be can you see this can somebody
and I'm sure maybe yes okay great thanks
so what we're gonna do is we're going to
enter some sentences and we're gonna
predict where the sentiment is positive
or negative okay so I'm gonna start with
this talk is interesting I'm gonna be
optimistic
I guess if somebody writes this I click
on the sentiment and what we can see so
I have two sentiment models one is
Transformer based which is the better
one and one is an RNN based model which
is the faster one
so they're both packaged in flair and as
you can see i hope you can see it
this talk is interested interesting was
classified as positive by both models
right if I now go ahead and say this
talk is not interesting
I do the prediction and and now it both
models actually very clearly say this is
negative because it's a very simple
example to classify right to maybe show
you a more complex example okay let's
say we we use something that's a little
bit sarcastic right so we say this talk
is about as interesting as watching
paint dry so it mentions interesting it
doesn't mention not but it says it's
about as interesting as watching paint
dry
so in this case what the models tell us
is that it's negative right so because
this is an expression you use in English
to say something is boring right this
words actually give away this imbalance
so if I remove this and I just say this
talk is as interesting as watching paint
dry then I do the sentiments detection
as you can see both models still tell us
that it's negative but the confidence is
actually dropped from like 99% to very
low confidence 50% right I'm gonna do
another one I'm gonna do this talk is as
interesting as watching let's say a
baseball game if I write this now both
my models will tell me that it's
positive because our models seem to
believe and baseball is interesting okay
and of course you can do this with real
data as well so I have a new newspaper
article here and if I put this in this
is from a newspaper article you see that
this statement which says something bad
about the economy's is classified as
negative right so you go back to the
talk okay so you have this type of model
so let's say you want to use it yourself
for your use case so basically this is
the full code that you need to do it as
you can see it's only like three or four
lines of codes the most important one is
this one so you do text classifier dot
load sentiment the very first time that
you call it it will download the pre
train model to your machine and if you
run this code again it doesn't do that
download again so it only does it on the
first first call and puts it into the
object then you put your text into a
sentence object you always have to wrap
your text into this object which allows
you to do like a bunch of cool stuff and
then all you really need to do is call
it a grid or predict and then you can
print the labels so it's just a few
lines of code
and then you know whether this piece of
text is positive or negative right
another task that we support a lot in
flair as a sequence labeling so I had an
example in the beginning of the talk the
most famous one is named entity
recognition where you want to identify
the names of people names what they are
are the names of people are the names of
locations are the names of organizations
or you want to go on to the words and
identify and part of speech tagging what
are the verbs in the sentence what are
the adjectives and again there's a lot
of different use cases why you would
want to do something like this right and
maybe to quickly show you a demo of this
as well so this is now the sequence
tagging demo I'm going to show you a few
different models I'm gonna start with a
simple sentence while you type I want to
read out the question I mean yes we're
asking where are the models downloaded
from so the models are stored on like an
aw nuts
bucket so basically yeah they're just
downloaded and it's something connected
directly to Claire it's like something
that Claire basically manages yeah
exactly so this is management flare so
basically internally it checks if the
model is already on your hard drive so
there's like a standard folder where all
the models go and if the model is not
there it'll download it from them from
the web and this is actually not only
for the models this is also for datasets
for instance so flayer actually includes
a lot of different datasets and also
word embeddings so basically everything
that you need there's this logic it
checks if it's there and if not it'll
it'll download it to your machine okay
okay in come on so to maybe show this
sentence George Washington was born
watching this by the way not true I'm
pretty sure it's not true but I use it
anyway to do named entity recognition on
this sentence will tell us that George
Washington is in fact a person these two
these two tokens together and Washington
is a location right it's also fairly
robust which is kind of cool which is
why I used as example if I say
Washington was born in Washington it'll
still know that the first Washington is
a person and the second Washington is a
location right to show you the
difference between entity recognition
and part of speech tagging I can also
just use part of speech tagging and now
what I get is the syntactic type of each
word in the sentence for instance I know
that sporran is now a verb and this can
be useful for certain things where you
want to extract information like what
kind of adjectives are being used what
kind of verbs are being used right to go
back to presentation so let's say you
want to do any of this you want to do an
image recognition or you want to do part
of speech tagging this is the code
snippet and you might notice that it
looks extremely similar to the one that
I showed you before that's because
there's only one line that's different
and the different line is this one so
you're going to load a different tagger
obviously right so this time you're
going to type sequence tiger dot load
POS for the part of speech tiger or load
NER for the NER attack tiger and again
the same logic is called so it downloads
the model on the first call to your
machine then again you're going to make
a text object for the text that you want
to classify and then you're just going
to Co entire it'll predict on the
sentence and that'll predict whatever
tax the model is trained to predict
alright
so that's two tasks that's
text ossification in sequence labeling
so another thing that I'd like to show
you is one model many languages
functionality that we have in flair as
well so basically in
in NLP what you typically have is you
have models or our language specific so
you might train a model to do any are
for English you might train it separate
model than to do any honor for German
right and this basically as a means that
you always have to do a language
detection first to say to see which
model you should use right but it's
actually possible to train a single
model using training data from multiple
languages and especially if we use
multilingual language models which we
have in flair right and what this what
then happens is that the language
identification becomes implicit to the
model so you can actually just give a
text in any languages and it'll just be
able to kind of deal with it so I want
to show you a demo of this as well I
hope it's not demo overkill no that's
not good hmm this works just doesn't
okay this works okay so I hope you can
still see everything so we go back to
the part of speech tagging example right
so we said George Washington was born in
Washington and we know born is a verb
let's let's add a different language to
this let's say George Washington water
in Washington cabal huh
same sentence in German so I'm gonna I'm
gonna parse this with the multilingual
model now and what happens is that even
though it's the same model seeing text
and different languages it's able to
predict correctly that capoeman is a
verb and born as a verb right so it can
handle this right another example that's
going to mine I'm not super sure
somebody correct me please I think this
means George Washington was born in
Washington in in French Guinea if I do
this tagging again at least me I'm
pretty sure that means Bourne is tagged
as a verb okay so you have you can
actually deal with these models with
text in many different languages and
that can make depending on your use case
if for instance you have I know for some
reason you have a website where people
enter text and all sorts of languages
this could could be useful for you okay
yes there's another question on YouTube
by Zeki and he asks how much data is
necessary to train for different
languages in this Flair model I assume
so I mean so then it's always the more
data you have to better so standard data
sets for sequence labeling tend to be
around 20,000 10 to 20,000 sentences of
annotated I think there's some data sets
that have less so generally I mean it's
always the more the more data you have
the better at least so with the
universal dependencies projects there's
actually a pretty good data available
for part of speech tagging form for many
different languages if that answers the
question I think that should answer the
question maybe the question and that
might be interesting for multi-lane must
languages be from the same family or
does it hold say between Finnish and
Portuguese yeah so Finnish is actually
funny because it's of course a super
crazy language so we in this paper that
we have here on the slide we trained it
for 12 languages and I think Finnish was
actually the the hardest one of all of
them so the other ones were from at
least the same language groups so like
Romance languages Germanic languages so
it's of course how
full if there's if they are in the same
group but if you have sufficient
training data for each language you can
still train a single model that that
does that works across all these
languages so even Finnish doesn't work
it's it's pretty good so it's not a must
okay we'll continue with the
presentation I will ask some more
questions that are post on YouTube and
in the chat later on yeah sure
[Music]
okay so this is maybe I wanted to give a
small list of some pre trained models
that we have in flair so obviously I
already showed sentiment analysis I've
showed oh I didn't actually show the
twelve class name into recognition so
this is 12 class is basically just more
classes so not just person location and
organization but even more there is part
of speech tagging for many different
languages we have something called
semantic frame detection syntactic
chunking and we have multilingual models
and I think there's also models for
stuff like hate speech detection so
essentially this is this is just a lot
of models that we ship with flair some
of them were trained by us many were
also trained by the community and so on
through the open-source community this
list is growing and growing so we are
supporting more and more languages with
this kind of stuff so so far we've seen
text classification and sequence
labeling but we also have a few other
NLP tests that are currently kind of
beta one of them is texts regression
which actually is pretty stable already
so essentially in this case you don't
want to predict a class label but you
want to predict like a value like 80
percent or like on on a spectrum right
so how how happy is this person or how
unhappy is this person this can can be
useful depending on your on your use
case and so that we already have the
architecture in flair so you can train
your own regression models and we also
have
data sets that we already ship with
flair for instance the Vasa 2018 share
task that is data that is annotated with
joy anger fear with certain emotions on
a scale from 0 to 100 okay
so you could train we've done it you can
train models that predict how angry a
person is just from the text right
another thing that's it's very very beta
but I'm very excited about this is
similarity learning so here what you
want to do is you have two data points
and these data points could be two texts
but they could also be a text on an
image which is what we've been working
with and you want to learn how similar
they are so essentially something like
an image like this dog catching a
frisbee should be very similar to the
text dog catching a frisbee in the park
right and for this we include currently
one data set the fighting a data set
that we actually developed also which is
fashion images so this is stuff from the
zalando time in German language
descriptions so but this is very beta
stuff so we we hope to develop this more
because I think similarity learning is
actually really exciting and there's a
lot of cool things that you can do with
it so here I'm and with all things I'm
very happy to collaborate with people if
anybody's interested in any of the stuff
where we're always happy to collaborate
since this is very much an open-source
product so what is the time you have
another I would say five to seven
minutes ok then I'm going to skip over
how to train your own model because it's
something we have tutorials online you
can just check it just take my word for
it that it's it's fairly easy to do you
know so let me just skip over that
hmm maybe just to show you the very last
slide of that that portion so this would
be a full example of how to train your
model so I'm not going to go through the
lines one by one just to show you it's
only a few lines of codes and it's it's
fairly easy to do and we we've seen a
lot of people also with very limited
background in Python even in Python -
who managed to train their own model so
it's it's very I think very easy to do
to conclude then so I introduced the
flare NOP framework so I showed some NOP
tasks specifically classification and
sequence labeling which really are the
big tests that we've been focusing on I
demoed some multilingual models and I
showed you some code snippets for
predicting and training that hopefully
convince you that the library is in fact
quite easy to use there is a release
coming this week I promise it will
include a lot of new embeddings new
datasets new pre-trained models it will
include for the first time fine tunable
transformers which work really well and
really have increased the accuracy for
the texts text classification parts and
there's a lot of refactoring some
simplifications of the code that we've
done that will be part of the next
release the immediate future will be
more so what we want to do is so we want
to actually add more tasks so next to
just these two tests that I've demoed
we're interested in branching out to
things like relation extraction semantic
role labeling information retrieval in
the context of similarity learning so
basically we you just want to support
and way more tasks and we feel that it's
actually possible to do it now because
now with my with my new my new job at
the University the manpower situation is
looking very different so it's I think
I've met a lot of very interested
students and I'm very optimistic that we
can actually get a lot of things done
now that previously we couldn't because
we just didn't have the manpower right
we want to include a lot more datasets
in languages and apply to new domains we
have a project already running called
hand flare that will be released
hopefully soon that will just include a
lot of new datasets and expand flare to
new domains and we're kind of excited
about adding new data types like images
or even complex types that are kind of
combinations between text and images or
semi structured data so this is kind of
a maybe but I would would be very
interested in doing this as well there's
a lot of research that of course we're
working on at the University so this
talk was really a focus from the
practitioner point of view but of course
what we do or our day job is research at
the University so we have a lot of fancy
neural language models that we want to
develops a lot of crazy ideas for word
embeddings that we want to put in there
we have we want to work more on this
multilingual 'ti aspect and there's a
lot of research in terms of hyper
parameter selection and neural
architecture search so I just broke this
and I'm gonna fix that because that's
important and since we're here at the
spelling mistake there's a question on
YouTube regarding the typos and the
correct spelling in the Flair embedding
and the Flair model what would happen
how would they react if the words were
spelt incorrectly yeah that's a great
question so essentially the answer
depends on the embeddings that you use
so our own embeddings that we developed
our character language and embeddings
and they tend to be fairly robust to
spelling errors but of course it all
breaks down so not sure which demo I can
use best to show this say what was what
let's use this demo
let's do this and see what happens and
for some reason it's still is able to
see that this is a location right if you
guys can see this so of course at some
point everything just goes goes crazy so
if I do something like this well okay
that still works for some reason because
born I think this is a very good do
something like this it still works okay
so it's it's it's fairly robust so in
and the reason for this is that the
language models that are powering this
at least the Flair language models are
at the character level meaning that they
they see words as sequences of
characters and are therefore able to do
a lot of guesswork Mads if that makes
sense that's I think that's fairly
robust yeah I think that answers the
question perfectly maybe another
question - like slide that you showed
before there's this question regarding
the RNN and transformers that you load
it and you used to do the sentiment
analysis I remember correctly are they
both implemented in flair no so
basically for the ardennes we just use
the default or intents that come out of
that coma light orange and the
Transformers we completely rely on the
hugging phase transformers
implementation so yes okay
okay and then maybe to wrap it up yes so
I just fixed to join us because that's a
very important part yes as I mentioned
before so this is an open-source project
there's no company and nobody's making
money so this this type of thing really
lives with people getting involved and
people becoming interested to contribute
to the open-source project so I would
like to invite anyone everybody to to
join us through the open-source project
if you're interested also with
collaborating with my group at the
University we're very open to any type
of collaboration I just and so this does
it
so we've already had questions but maybe
there's more questions thank you okay
thank you very much there's another
question I see
it's from Dahl and he is asking if if
these models are ever updated if they're
like how are they trained basically if
you train a model is this model ever
retrained in a sense so you have the
option of retraining it so essentially I
mean the classic pipeline would be that
you train it over your training data and
then you just have to model but what is
possible is to take an existing model
and continue training it if for instance
new training data comes around so for
instance I know some people are using it
in an active learning type scenario
where you add new training data points
over different iterations and in this
case it's possible to essentially
continue training a model and so the
training could never be seen as complete
in a sense so you can always continue
training it if you want okay cool
there's another question on YouTube how
would you decide whether to use
tensorflow or PI torch
so I think I mean this is this is two
years ago so but at the time at least my
personal opinion was that my torch was
way more usable than tensorflow and in
fact it was actually before tens of flow
editors Eagle eager modes functionality
so a lot of the things that we are doing
and flare would not have been possible
with play torch with with tensorflow
back then because we use these dynamic
computation grants actually a lot okay
cool I don't see any further questions I
guess
oh yeah there's another question about
the French language is there any model
in entity of detection NT recognition
relation extraction in this open source
project I think we have a French any
other so we definitely have a French
part of speech tagging model and I'm
pretty sure we have a French NER model
as well so French is definitely included
in the multilingual models and I think
we have dedicated models for French as
well so French was not trained by us but
it was trained by a community member but
I'm pretty sure it's there okay is is it
possible to examine a whole passage or a
conversation not only a sentence to the
site positive or negative sentiment it's
generally possible so with transformers
currently actions not with the
transformer based model because the
transformers have a a maximum sequence
length that's a harder restriction if
you use the iron n based model it is
possible personally I've so we've
trained the model with passages of
maximum 50 words because I kind of feel
like at some point if your text is long
there might be multiple sentiments right
if so the the newspaper article that I
just very briefly short has some
positive news and some negative news
so I think it would be kind of hard to
say this I mean you can probably still
say it but I feel like it's actually
maybe more useful to if you have a big
text to chop it down and into paragraphs
or sentences and just and do sentiment
analysis on each one of them to get your
results okay
there are a couple more questions I
think we should start with the question
about Flair versus Spacey what's the
difference why why should I use Flair
instead of Spacey for example yeah I'm
kind of I'm not super happy with this
kind of question because I I actually
don't yeah so I don't have enough
experience with with working with Spacey
myself to answer this question very well
so the last time I answered it I ended
up saying something that was actually
wrong about Spacey generally I think you
should work with flair if you like the
type of abstraction that we have so
basically this idea of having access to
a lot of different word embeddings that
are coming out of research right now and
you want to apply this this research
immediately to your to your projects but
at the end of the day I think it comes
down to preference so the abstractions
that you like the functionality that you
that you prefer it's it's it's a bit
hard for me to give a good good answer
to this okay
there is another question about again by
at all this is from the meetup chat
whether the security of these public
models is an issue I mean basically you
could edit the data or create some data
that will train in the sense that well
some president candidates and this will
map to negative sentiment is this an
issue yeah I mean so if if you for
instance if you manipulate the training
data in such a way you could bias the
model so that's
that's possible so in our case we've
we've used just publicly available
datasets for sentiment analysis so in
this case it's basically for instance
the the data that we used was trained on
Amazon reviews product reviews and movie
reviews so and there's there's going to
be biases in that data and these biases
will be in the model as well so yeah
that's that can happen okay but Claire
doesn't really curate the data itself I
mean there is no part of Flair that
specifically is responsible for curating
the data and being responsible and asset
for like having some quality measures
for the data set that is used to train
the model know so basically the only
curation we do is to kind of try to
filter out low-quality water points so
basically there's always noise
especially in these in these data sets
so we do filter out no hiss but we
haven't really looked into like this
type of political biases or this kind of
stuff but we're interested so if
somebody's interested in doing that that
would be really great okay
I would say that I'll read another two
or I think I've only seen other two
questions on YouTube which is geared
towards the GPT two and it's just a
general question what do you think about
it what do you think about GPT to work
so I think we included also in it's also
included via hugging phase transformers
into flare I have not experimented too
much with it so because we actually have
a lot of like different embeddings so
what GPT - I haven't really worked too
much so I can't really say too much
about it
okay and I think the last question if I
oh yeah that's I think a question
regarding again the sentiment analysis
you had an example that was basically
one of these borderline examples where
you can't really fix the sentiment one
way or the other where you had like this
51% towards negative why isn't there a
neutral sentiment the original model we
actually had a neutral sentiment it's
India I removed it because it there was
too much noise in the training data so
this is really just a problem of the
data set if you have a data set that has
a good neutral carat category then
that's that's great so essentially to go
back so so the tenth sentiment data for
the most part is trained over Amazon
product reviews where people give
between one and five stars right and so
the problem is that if people give for
instance three stars the language use is
actually extremely different so some
people will say three stars that's
pretty good and some people will give
three stars if something's complete
completely terrible so the model was
actually having differences just because
the signal wasn't that great the mono
was having a lot of problems trying to
find out what neutral actually is if
that makes sense so in the end what we
did is we actually only used one star
and two star reviews as negative and
only five star reviews as positive to
just have a better separation of
language of what these two things are
and then we kind of say that if because
the model always puts a probability or
like a confidence value for instance
we've seen that the negative confidence
in this one example was very low and
then in in your use case you could say
if the confidence is not so high that
it's either negative or positive then
I'm just going to treat this as as a
neutral
[Music]
okay maybe one last question which is
Garrett specifically get towards you and
then I think well thank you and because
it was a really great talk how can I
join join you Alan via LinkedIn question
mark LinkedIn that's that's that's
that's totally fine
join the open-source community that's
that's the easiest way so like I said so
we're we're happy to to to work together
with anyone that we can so okay in that
case I want to thank you and I think the
entire PI data group that is here on
Zoom and also on YouTube is I think very
happy with the talk and it was very
interesting so again thank you for
talking know what do you want to say
something yeah sure thank you everyone
for coming
our next meetup will probably also be
online on June 17th so we had to miss
theory we had the contest that we
announced in the beginning of the Meetup
and we had two contestants from China
but they haven't emailed us yet so and
we have been contacted by the attendee
from Argentina so now he is front runner
for getting the amazing pie date of
stickers please join us again you can
find us on meetup or on Twitter and we
also have website which we can quickly
post on the on the YouTube chat for
people who are not familiar with hi
database nothing I hope you are doing it
quickly
yeah and have everyone a very nice
evening
we have also recorded the talk and they
will be published sooner than later okay
so I guess that concludes our may PI
data meet up and we'll see you next time
okay bye-bye
bye everybody